let's talk a little bit about the life
cycle of a cell in particular we're
going to talk about interphase
the interphase part of the life cycle of
a cell and as we'll see interphase is
where a cell spends most of its life
let's draw a timeline for a cell so
let's say this is a this is a i guess
you could say a new cell
and
it will go through interphase
so i'm going to make it like a cycle so
it's going to go back on itself and at
some point so all of that is interphase
at some point it will be ready to divide
and it will undergo mitosis and mitosis
is more formally it's the process by
which the nucleus turns into two nuclei
but then that's obviously needed for
cell division so this is mitosis right
here in green so as you see and this
isn't precise a cell spends most of its
life in interphase and that's where it's
just you kind of living as a cell it's
living growing producing proteins
whatever
other functions it has and mitosis it's
a shorter part of its life a smaller
fraction a very interesting part it's
necessary in order for the cell to
replicate but you see it's a much
smaller fraction but what i want to
focus on in this video is interphase and
to do that let's draw ourselves a cell
so let me copy and paste
so this right over here
actually let me i did that just to save
time
so let's say this is a cell so in green
i have its nuclear member or not nuclear
have its cell membrane inside of that of
course you have all of the you have all
of the cytosol and then in this in this
orangish color i have the nuclear
membrane that defines the nucleus and
then inside of that i have the dna
and you might be used to seeing dna all
tightly bound or chromosomes all tightly
bound
like that
and
like that this or like
this this would be another chromosome
right over here in magenta but during
interphase the chromosomes aren't
tightly bound like that so that they're
easy to see from a traditional or a
simple light microscope for most of a
cell's life the chromosomes are
completely unwound they are in their
chromatin form
so they are in their chromatin form it's
actually hard to see if you have just a
simple microphone a simple microscope
it's all unwound you just have the
proteins and the dna it's all tangled
together now there's one other thing
that i drew here and
this is you might say why am i drawing
it when i haven't drawn most of the
other organelles but i'm drawing this
thing which is called a centrosome
because it's going to be it's going to
be important for
it's going to be important when we go
into mitosis
now this drawing as well you might say
wait doesn't doesn't a cell at least a
human cell a kind of a the diplo that
has a diploid number of chromosomes and
once again if we're not talking about
sex cells if we're talking about just
our somatic cells doesn't have 46
chromosomes it looks like you only drew
two and it is true i only drew two
chromosomes for the sake of simplicity
we're just going to assume this is a
cell of some organism that's much
simpler that it only has
two chromosomes so anyway this is the
new cell right over here and it is going
to grow
so it is going to grow it's going to
take in nutrients from its environment
and it's going to grow as we would
expect it to
so that's that right over there and then
let me give it
its nucleus and its centrosome just like
that
and this phase
this phase where it is just growing from
this new cell
this is
this phase right over here is the g1
phase the g1 actually let me do that in
a different color since i'm already
using that green so much this is the g1
phase and so that might look something
like this different cells are going to
do this for different periods of time
the g1 phase
but then you can imagine well look it's
going to need to replicate some of the
info or it's going to replicate the
information inside of the or that's
that's coded by the dna at some point
and actually this happens before mitosis
and so let's depict that
so let me draw
let me draw the nucleus and the
centrosome again
so let me draw that again and let me
draw
the cellular membrane
this nice healthy
growing cell and now its dna is actually
going to replicate so instead of having
one copy of of its dna it's essentially
going to go to two copies but i want to
be very very careful now so if i draw
that magenta chromosome up here so once
again it's all unwound like that
when it replicates it's going to create
a copy of its dna and once again i'm not
doing justice for how much dna
how much dna there actually is
but it was one chromosome before it was
one chromosome when it was just like
this and it's still one chromosome even
though it's copied its genetic material
let me draw this a little bit neater
so this is one chromosome right over
here and that one chromosome after it's
copied all of its genetic material it is
still one chromosome now how do we how
do you know but there's two copies over
here what do we call these two copies
well each of these two copies are called
a chromatid and these two right over
here these are sister chromatids
sister
chromatids but either way this is one
chromosome right over here chromosome
chromosome
and this is also so this is one
chromosome right over there and that is
also one chromosome this whole thing
right over here is also one chromosome
later on when we go through mitosis
we'll see that these two sister
chromatids get split apart they're no
longer connected and at that point we
refer to each of them as an individual
chromosome
now you might be wondering is there a
word for this place where these two
sister chromatids are connected and the
answer is yes there is a word and that
word is centromere not to be conver
confused with centrosomes so let me give
myself some space here so that right
over here that is a centro
centro
ver right over that so we had one
magenta or this we had this magenta
chromosome right over here and now it
replicates it's still one chromosome
although it has twice the genetic
material right now you have these two
sister chromatids connected at the say
the centromeres right over there and
that's also going to happen for the blue
chromosome all this genetic material is
going to replicate you're going to have
two copies of it and so now it's going
to be made up of two sister chromatids
that are maybe connected once again at
at a centromere and also while all of
this replication is happening inside the
nucleus the centrosome also duplicates
the centrosome
also
also duplicates and this process the
part of the life cycle where all of this
genetic information is duplicating we
call that the s phase s phase for
synthesis
so this is the synthesis phase
so that is the s phase and then before
going into mitosis there's one more
growth phase
there's one more
growth phase and we call that g2
so we have one more growth phase
which we call g2
and then we are ready so let me just
copy and paste this
actually let me just do this so that's
what we had before
now we need to remember that our dna has
replicated
so our dna is replicated
so let me draw that like that let me
draw the two
centromeres
for one for each of the chromosomes
let me draw the center the replicated
the duplicated centrosome that's not to
be confused with centromere and now the
cell has grown even more
the cell has grown
the cell has grown even more and once
again
going from this to this we call that the
g2 phase
and at this point at the end of the g2
phase this is now when we are ready
this is now let me do this in a
different color this is now when we are
ready for mitosis